my heart broke into a million pieces
Anna zargaryen was only 19 weeks
pregnant when her water broke her doctor
told her she had almost no chance of
carrying her baby to term and her own
life was threatened Texas doctors told
her they couldn't perform an abortion so
she traveled to Colorado what was it
like to have to leave
Texas your home
it's terrifying I felt like a shell of a
human but I was just like you know
wrapped up in grief zargaryen is now one
of five women suing the state of Texas
over its abortion law it is now
dangerous
to be pregnant in Texas after the
Supreme Court overturned Roe v Wade last
summer a state trigger law banned
abortion unless a woman's life is at
risk or the fetus has a fatal diagnosis
and doctors who provide the procedure
outside those limited circumstances face
the possibility of life in prison